>>> A MESSY AND MYSTERIOUS
MOMENT FOR DEMOCRATS TODAY ABOUT
UKRAINE.
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS SENT A LETTER
TO THE WHITE HOUSE YESTERDAY
URGING PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
NEGOTIATE AN END TO THE WAR.
THEN SHE ISSUED A CLARIFICATION.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
WE ARE UNITED AS DEMOCRATS, WE
SUPPORT PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THE EARLIER LETTER URGED THE
PRESIDENT TO PURSUE VIGOROUS
DIPLOMACY, INCLUDING DIRECT
TALKS WITH RUSSIA.
OTHER PROGRESSIVES SAY THIS
LETTER WAS DRAFTED SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO AND SET ASIDE.
IT HAS BEEN HARD TO GET AN
ANSWER AS TO WHY IT WAS SENT
NOW.
MANU RAJU JOINS OUR
CONVERSATION.
DO WE KNOW WHY, AND A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING WHAT THE
HELL HAPPENED HERE?
>> WE'VE BEEN ASKING THIS
QUESTION ALL MORNING.
JAYAPAL'S OFFICE HAS DECLINED TO
COMMENT WHY THIS WAS SENT OUT
THIS WEEK, JUST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS WHEN THE PARTY IS
TRYING TO SHOW A UNITED FRONT.
IT'S THE REPUBLICANS RIGHT NOW
WHO ARE SPARRING ABOUT WHETHER
TO PROVIDE MORE AID TO UKRAINE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE THAT
DEBATE.
BUT THIS LETTER OPENED UP A NEW
FRONT THAT A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
DID SIMPLY NOT WANT TO DISCUSS.
THEY DID SIGN ONTO THIS LETTER,
ABOUT 30 OF THEM, BACK IN JULY
CALLING FOR A BIGGER PUSH
TOWARDS DIPLOMACY.
BUT A NUMBER OF THEM THAT I
TALKED TO TODAY, AND SOME HAVE
SAID IT PUBLICLY TODAY, SAID
THEY WOULD NOT SIGN ON TO THE
LETTER NOW GIVEN WHERE THE WAR
IS WITH UKRAINE AT THIS MOMENT.
SO THE FACT THAT JAYAPAL SENT
THIS OUT TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS BLINDSIDING
HER MEMBERS HAS CAUSED A LOT OF
BACKLASH.
ONE HOUSE DEMOCRAT SAID, QUOTE,
PEOPLE ARE FURIOUS.
>> LET'S JUST GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE SAMPLING.
MARK POCAN SAYS I HAVE NO IDEA
WHY IT WENT OUT NOW.
NUMBER ONE, TO MANU'S POINT, IT
IS A POLICY DIVERGENCE DEBATE AT
A KEY MOMENT IN THE WAR.
NUMBER TWO, A CYNICAL PERSON
MIGHT SUGGEST THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE POST ELECTION
COMPETITION FOR LEADERSHIP.
>> YOU THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE MESSY.
I THINK NANCY PELOSI WAS ASKED A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO WHETHER OR
NOT SHE'S GOING TO BE SPEAKER.
IS SHE GOING TO BE IN A
LEADERSHIP ROLE, MAYBE SPEAKER,
MAYBE SOME OTHER ROLE.
SHE BASICALLY REFUSED TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
BUT YES, THE YOUNGER MEMBERS ARE
CHOMPING AT THE BIT.
THE MORE PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS
CHOMPING AT THE BIT FOR A
LEADERSHIP TURNOVER FROM THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN IN THOSE
LEADERSHIP ROLES FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS.
AND SO THIS IN SOME WAYS COULD
BE AN INDICATION OF THAT.
IT COULD BE AN INDICATION OF THE
TOUGH SLEDDING BIDEN COULD HAVE
GOING FORWARD.
KEVIN McCARTHY SAID THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE A BLANK CHECK FOR
UKRAINE PARTICULARLY IF
AMERICANS ARE MIRED IN A
RECESSION.
NOW YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATS ALSO
SUGGESTING SOME SKEPTICISM --
>> AND McCARTHY SAYS NO BLANK
CHECK BECAUSE OF INFLATION.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT TAKING THE
TUCKER CAUCUS POSITION THAT SAYS
GIVE UKRAINE TO PUTIN.
THAT'S WHAT THE TUCKER WING OF
THE PARTY SAYS, WHO CARES, GIVE
IT TO PUTIN.
BUT THEY DID SAY THIS CONFLICT
HAS ALSO CONTRIBUTED TO ELEVATED
GAS AND FOOD PRICES AT HOME.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES POSITION IS, YES, THAT
MAY WELL BE TRUE, BUT IT IS
WORTH IT.
THIS IS A GLOBAL CRISIS.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT, IT'S WORTH IT
FOR DEMOCRACY AT THIS POINT.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU HEAR HIM SAY
THIS IS PART OF THIS GLOBAL
BATTLE BETWEEN DEMOCRACY AND
AUTOCRACY.
EVEN LAST WEEK YOU SAW THE LINE
OF ATTACK FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
FROM DEMOCRATS POINTING TO THOSE
COMMENTS FROM KEVIN McCARTHY
SAYING WE'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE
UKRAINE A BLANK CHECK,
CRITICIZING IT.
THE CONCERN IS THAT THIS LETTER
COULD UNDERMINE THAT CRITICISM
COMING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
AGAINST REPUBLICANS.
>> IF YOU'RE SITTING AT HOME
WATCHING THIS CONVERSATION OR
READING ABOUT THIS AND THINKING
WHY DOES ANY OF THIS MATTER?
HOW DOES ANY OF THIS IMPACT ME?
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW
THE BASES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
EMPOWERED IN BOTH PARTIES
BECAUSE A CLEAR MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE AND SENATE, IF YOU'RE --
>> THE BIPARTISAN MAJORITY.
>> THINKS THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO, EVEN IF IT MEANS
HIGHER GAS PRICES, EVEN IF IT
MEANS SOME ECONOMIC PAIN, EVEN
IF IT SWINGS MAJORITY CONTROL
BECAUSE IT'S THE U.S. VERSUS
RUSSIA ALL OVER AGAIN.
IT'S NATO AND THE POST WORLD WAR
II COALITION VERSUS AUTOCRACY,
RIGHT?
BUT EVERYBODY IS SO AFRAID OF
THEIR SHADOW AND OF THEIR BASES
THAT THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT CAN
THEY JUST DO THIS IN THE LAME
DUCK SESSION?
IF THEY COULD, THERE WOULD BE A
PLAN ALREADY.
>> THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT SO
INTERESTING IN THE SENSE WE
SHOULD ENCOURAGE POLICY DEBATES.
THE QUESTION HERE IS WHY NOW?
>> AND THE PRESSURE ON THE
LEADERSHIP TO YOUR POINT IS
WHETHER OR NOT TO DEAL WITH THIS
WHEN THEY GET BACK RIGHT AFTER
THE ELECTION BEFORE POTENTIALLY
A REPUBLICAN TAKEOVER IN
JANUARY, WHICH WOULD MAKE
GETTING MORE AID DIFFICULT AND
WHETHER THESE BASES WILL GET
MORE INFLUENTIAL WITHIN THOSE
RESPECTIVE CAUCUSES.
THERE IS A PUSH TO DO IN IN THE
LAME DUCK SESSION OF CAUCUS BUT
THEY'LL NEED SUPPORT TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WE SEE SOME SUPPORT
WANING.
>> IT IS WORTH ADDING THAT THERE
ARE SOME FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS
THAT ARE QUESTIONING HOW IS THIS
GOING TO END AND WHAT ARE THE
OFF-RAMPS HERE.
AND IF ANY SORT OF NEGOTIATION
THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE THE U.S.
AND IS JUST UKRAINE AND RUSSIA
WILL BE TAKEN AS JET.
BU